so thank you everyone for joining uh
really appreciate it
so this is uh the first this kind of a
pilot of what we're calling uh open
source chats so what what is the goal of
Open Source chats it's a lounge Curtis a
lounge excuse me yeah I brought my water
too so the oh it is opens for chats okay
it's our Lounge yeah there's two main
goals I am curious how much what you
guys prefer so first and foremost
um a goal is just to connect users of
the tool to the people who developed
that tool so uh developers can sometimes
feel a little disconnected from end
users it's probably not a case with Rich
here
um and then users often you know are
unaware of how these open source
software tools get made and get
maintained uh and then open source
software just works better with an
active and engaged Community uh and a
better connection between developers
like rich and end users uh like yourself
or other contributors developers like
yourself uh and then secondly just
thinking this as an opportunity for you
guys to share with each other how you
use the tool and how you approach common
problems so with that in mind we would
love to hear questions from you you I'm
Curtis I work at our studio soon to be
posits on the community team and we'll
introduce rich in a moment also uh a
good portion of you may be watching this
in the future right after the live event
um and you know I like to imagine this
post-apocalyptic landscape in the
distant future where someone somehow got
access to a YouTube data center or
something
um if you have those questions just go
to the GT package Twitter accounts Rich
would be able to respond to you there
it's a good account yeah yeah cool so
just introductions
um so this is Rich uh he's on the our
Studios uh quarto Team soon to be uh
positive or as as you may or may not
know our students changing its name
deposit for a number of reasons uh and
is the maintainer of the GT package the
GT package strives to empower anyone to
make wonderful looking tables with r uh
the philosophy is we can construct a
wide variety of useful tables with a
cohesive set of Table parts and then
this is done uh with our package that
has an number of helper strives to be
intuitive and easy use and helps you
make kind of custom tables so there's
many helper functions that help you
modify and customize your table uh it
sort of assumes where you start with
this data frame uh and then a table is
built up of stubs summary rows titles
subtitles columns headers footnotes
Source notes and then there's a number
of formatter functions for the values of
that table and then uh the other goal is
to have to offer you a wide variety of
output formats currently supported is
HTML PDF or logic uh I think it's law
Tech to mpf which checks RTF files uh
which I love that it's called Rich Text
files since we have Rich here and then
recently added text files
sorry recently added is was word doc
um
so most questions uh will come from the
audience but we have pre-arranged a
bunch of questions just to kind of get
things the ball running but we we do
intend to switch to this discussion and
questions from all y'all and then so if
you work with GT actively now if you
have feedback if you're struggling
create tables that you need this event
is designed for you it's very much
interacting with with Rich As the
maintainer of the GT package so yeah
thanks for joining us rich yeah thanks
for having me this is great the
inaugural Lounge event yeah I really
appreciate you doing this uh pilot and
experiment yeah and I and I also really
appreciate everyone who's joining us as
well so just the first question to get
out of the way is um how do I pronounce
your last name because I recently
learned I've mispronounced it yeah it's
a tough long time um I go with Ian or
you know it's time even it's probably
the best of your best bet so Ian none as
it's basically spelled here but yes yeah
yeah okay awesome so I should know that
next serious question is I I look back
at your talk and I think 2019's uh our
studio conference you joined in 2018
I've been working on this since May or
March of 2018. not like me um yeah yeah
yeah so I mean if you could I gave a
little introduction to GT if you if you
could kind of give your introduction and
why are you spending so much time on do
I you know why are we why are you
investing so much into this
yeah I think it's mostly because there's
so many problems to solve
um I worked on it
um we had the initial release like in
late 2018 and then soon after
tons and tons of issues
um which was great you know I love
issues
um but they're all sorts like little
things like that some things I thought
of but something some things I didn't
and I'm still getting these issues even
with lots of like changes and tweaks and
additions uh I think there's so many
things that people want out of tables
because it's kind of a creative Pursuit
and
um it's a bit like a visualization in a
way there's no like harm and fast rules
you can do whatever pretty much as long
as you have some sort of rid of numbers
or uh or you know otherwise but yeah
there's tons of stuff to do so I just
kept doing it nobody told me to stop
um
yeah and there's so much to do
especially in just the static table uh
scenario just like you know tables on a
page or on a website
um
yeah yeah I think we're almost getting
to the end of like the conceivable
things that people want
that's why I'm sort of Shifting my
attention to like other things like
um you know those questions I had you
know branching out me into other output
formats or getting interactive
um but I still I still think there'll be
a lot of work even in the non-attractive
case because there's so many small
things you can do
uh to make better and I I have a kind of
a said I've warned you about this
question it's a little bit vague but
it's okay
um just to set things up right as as a
company one of our goals is to support
open source software for data science so
can you tell me like you know you could
conceivably working as a developer at a
fancy software company not that deposit
it's not fancy but yeah so so why are
you investing so much into open source
like why why is this an open source
package why why do you care so much yeah
why do open source in general I think
it's great because you have this
um interaction with the community you
get like issues you get to talk to
people in the issues you get PRS people
are sometimes sitting in their first or
uh maybe they're experienced we have
different levels of people coming in uh
but it's great you're helping people
sort of like you know contribute it's
like all about
um interaction and contributions and uh
it's great to see something like develop
kind of like semi-organically that way I
know like you know like the maintainer
probably is like One Vision but it can
be totally steered and shaped uh by
people in the community and I think
that's kind of wonderful in a way
so what would be your message to why
right if I have some options for
developing a any sort of software why as
a user would I maybe prefer
open source over some alternative that's
not yeah yeah lots lots of reasons um
well one thing is like if you see like a
thing that you you want or something
that's not quite right it could be a bug
or an enhancement you could just make
the pr and convince the person to accept
it or you know like work towards getting
that accepted and that could be really
fast I've seen it happen within a matter
of you know in best cases hours
um you know sometimes it can happen over
a longer period but
it'll happen way faster than closed
Source software I can tell you that at
least have a fighting chance with open
source and like if the project is active
um
it's extremely fast it's it's amazing
actually how fast you make changes and
how much you can sort of help a project
out just if even if you're on the
outside
awesome well thank thanks a bunch
um well so as a reminder to folks um
feel free to ask some post some
questions and to into the zoom chat as
well as if you're keen on more of an
anonymous type structure
um there's a slide a link at rsdb.io OS
chat feel free to drop stuff in there
um the second half will switch to
discussion that sort of thing
um just to get the ball rolling uh We've
set up a couple questions uh focused on
GT GT 0.7 just came out
um could you kind of introduce you know
what's in GT 0.7 and tell us a bit about
what one of the parts right is this
Vector formatting functions yeah that's
kind of a big thing
um okay there's two like really big
things uh the first is uh the first
support for docx output like word output
format so that's just beginning so um
you know keep your expectations not too
high because it's just beginning so
there's going to be a few like sort of
like things to sort of like patch over
uh but at least it's a start so we've
got that sort of going
um the other thing is yeah this uh the
vector formatting functions
um and I can show you that because it's
kind of a big thing so we spent a lot of
time making these formatting functions
so you can get your values and whatnot
formatted just like how you want them
I'm going to share my screen
and I'll show you I got this like
document I set up and it's got all these
things in here and it's actually a lot
of functions if you look at these these
are all the functions I add in in 0.7
they all begin with vac underscore fmt
so the existing functions are just
beginning with f and T so those are
already in the package like pre 0.7 but
we add these ones that begin back and
continue on the same name so the idea
here is you can just like use those
formatters uh outside of GT if you want
um
so you have a vector you just format it
and you have the same arguments that you
would have uh in the sort of like the
function that was there before
so it's better to show things to tell
because it's a little confusing
um so let me just show you so I got this
factor of numbers just uh you know some
some numbers and I'll use vector format
number on this and then if you look at
my console it just formats them to two
decimal places because that's the
default for that so I can change that to
like three decimal places
so kindly so we're totally outside of GT
we just have a vector and we're using
the same functions that you would use to
format Columns of values for reason
outside so
why do this well there's this thing
called our markdown in quarto or you
know other things like that you may just
want to have formatted values in your
text so you can have these inline sort
of like
um R pieces or our chunks and you just
throw in like a vector like a VEC format
function in there and you know I get the
same sort of treatment as you would in
your table which is super cool
uh so I'll show you a few more examples
just to acquaint people
um so you have some options here for the
separator Mark and the decimal Mark you
can change those so basically those are
reversed
um so other you know locales will have
that by default so you just insert the
Locale like here's France and we have
the same sort of thing right there that
takes care of that
there's a bunch of options basically the
same options as I said that are in
format number which is this function
here
and here's the help doc
basically all these carryover
which is kind of cool
um so if we did this
Force sign equals true more examples
that means like you get a plus sign
always that's pretty good if you want to
show change from a value
uh drop shailing zeros so that means
like any zeros are at the end will be
dropped
accounting we have that
and you can always use a pattern if you
want to Adorn your values with some sort
of text either before or after so that's
like a sort of review
um
and it's kind of neat because this is
just like in the console we're getting
our values just formatted
yeah
um this reminds me of scales a bit like
you often have to pull on scales yeah GT
plot exactly exactly so we have vector
format currency
and we do the same sort of thing with
dumbbells
and speaking of which there's in scales
sorry
um dollar
and you can do the same sort of thing
like uh number else I believe works
same sort of thing except in Scales
there's only a dollar in Euro I believe
and there might be pound but uh you know
Vector for my currency has basically
every single currency type so which is
kind of eat so you just choose the
currency in there
um so that's kind of sort of same sort
of use case uh if you're using this
outside of gdplot just inside text uh
you can use these they're sort of
interchangeable
which is kind of
yeah that's I could I can imagine you
put in a ton of work so that you your
users could customize the look and feel
of a value within the table and that's
yeah I've you've showed me you know I've
gone through sort of if you include all
the parameterizations and all the
examples of those we're talking about
hundreds of different ways to look at
things right and so basically with this
is it's now available outside to anyone
so you could put it into a GD plot or a
plot exactly or inside text inside
picture inline or bit yeah
um I'll show you a new function we have
there's actually two of them because you
know we have this two like a set of two
now uh format duration and vect format
duration uh it's kind of neat because I
can just like provide examples with the
deck form and just show them the console
it's kind of like a nice way to avoid
seeing a table each time
um but this is all about duration values
um you may not use them very much but if
you need them this is great because it
provides so many different ways to like
provide these human readable durations
uh so like you know 81 weeks two days 20
hours 24 minutes 32 seconds it kind of
does that automatically uh so I don't
know if you know about diff time values
but they're you can use those or you can
just use numerical values and provide
the unit so two different ways to sort
of like put your inputs into this
uh but there's like tons and tons of
options here so again I use the help a
lot uh if you just go to format duration
uh you'll see just a pretty large number
of like different like uh Arguments for
tweaking
um the values and of course I I have
examples here at the end
um but let me just show you a few of
these just to give you a flavor of
what's in there so we have that we can
also like just constrain the output
units so this in this case it just stays
we can provide a vector like that
and we can also it's a little bit off
the page here but change the style of
duration just four different styles so y
just means we're not using H or M we're
using like the the words essentially
like this
which is kind of cool
and uh a big thing I do in GT is because
I know this package goes all over the
world is have locales like a Locale
setting in each formatter function
and that should basically this is not a
machine look how it's basically
independent from your actual setup
uh but if you put yes it'll produce like
Spanish
um
uh durations which is kind of cool
if I build a shiny app and I somehow
collected Locale information from the
user is that something I could pass on
or is that sorry yeah absolutely yeah
like there's tons of accounts if I just
changed this
um like it's that so it's like I think
700 and they're all translated and
formatted correctly uh because there'll
be all sorts of like differences in the
way this is like patterned so
so a lot of time went into that uh
making sure that worked
so but I'm really happy that we have all
this like for every single formatter
function now
um we also have another one I just want
to show you one more it's a scientific
one
because I want to draw your attention to
like some special stuff at the end
um okay first of all scientific notation
a new thing is now we have like a plain
version of like scientific notation so
this right here if you look at this uh
it's just basically like meant to be
sort of like inline in a console this is
called the plane
um for landing Style
and you don't really know this but by
default there's actually a output
which is called Auto so when the console
it'll just be plain but you can force
that to be like plain
like this
um so I'm just going to zoom ahead and
sort of get it what I'm trying to show
you this output argument it now like can
make the it can make the outputs like
HTML litek or RTF so I'll show you that
because you know this is stuff that's
kind of hard to type out or to promote
yourself
but if you have an HTML document it's
perfect because it'll be formatted
nicely if you have a latex document
same sort of thing
sort of stuff that's a little bit hard
to write yourself maybe
impossible to do in like GT right now
anyways
RTF is right there so the idea here is
because we have it as Auto
we can just put this in like quarto and
it'll it'll detect what the output is
and it'll just choose so if you have an
HTML document recorder it'll choose a
nice formatting which is basically using
tags so let me show you that
um so I had no idea that yeah that's
amazing yeah there's like so much stuff
going on that's why it's like oh my God
I gotta show you all this uh so we have
a coral document right here so we're
just setting it up with GT entire verse
uh we're making a table uh there's a
nice data set inside GT called pizza
place I make a pizza summary I make a
table and then I display the table
finally
great okay but the thing I want to show
you is the new thing basically in this
little inline code chunk with back take
r
so I've got an object to Pizza summary
which is a table and I'm pulling a value
out of it and then I'm getting the max
one the the max element of the vector
and then I'm using one of those Vector
formatic functions and I don't have to
like specify like the type like the
output it's just Auto kind of knows
um
what we're doing but this is really kind
of neat because like it gives you like
the HTML like formatting and with
diagonal like as a layout it's got a
nice slash and like the number on the
left is superscripted and subscripted on
the right kind of hard to pull off if
you're just doing yourself
um but you can do it here which is kind
of cool
um
and there's also some a bonus as well uh
in version 0.8 which is not released yet
but it's in like the Dead version we
have another function called extract
cells which allows you to just from a GT
object take a format and still write out
so you don't have to like redo all this
stuff uh so there's like two ways to to
do things so basically the four magnets
applied will just be like taken and put
into the uh into the document
let me just show you that I'll render
this yeah I feel like you've been
setting it up and teasing us a lot of
setup yeah but uh the final result will
be really cool but it's good to see like
you know where it's coming from and you
know the source and the output okay so
here's the table well here's the source
for the table
the table so you can see we have
fractions here nicely formatted
uh really cool but here in the text look
at this uh five over ten in that sort of
fancy HTML way so with tags
uh same here what we did here is two out
of ten because we've targeted the column
F sold you don't know what it is because
it's actually
um
you know like right here in this pizza
summary
or actually no it's in the GT table and
then um rows 14. so we just grabbed row
14 which I believe is the last one and
it's 2010. so basically this formatted
value you don't repeat that because it
already knows what the formatting is
you're just sort of grabbing it and then
putting here which is super cool if you
want to cite values in a table you don't
have to like you know like uh run the
risk of having formatting errors or like
uh transcription errors you just it's
like you're just pulling it which is
kind of
uh so I just wanted to show you there
that's like one of the sort of like cool
things about
um the vector formatting functions and
that new function extracts cells
does GT have a cheat sheet because no I
guess I feel like the back of that
should probably be just showing you
giving you a sense of the scope like
like I said yeah you have a couple dozen
functions and then when you include all
the parameter options you're now getting
into hundreds of ways to customize it
yeah you feel like we yeah it would be
awesome to be able to quickly review
kind of what our options are so I guess
it's just assume that there probably is
an option and then dive into your docs
to if that's that's pretty much yeah
what I've done to help that is to make
the man files like the help files here
at least as much information as
information as possible
um they're huge documents but they at
least have examples and I try to like
you know flesh things out in like detail
sections right here like this if it
warrants more explanation but at least
try to have like group just reproducible
examples
um so this table like this code will
produce this table
and it really should be more like stuff
like that
um but you know at least there's like a
guarantee of one per help article
and also the other thing I pledge to do
is for each help article just show one
function instead of like a bunch of
functions at one time uh less confusing
and uh kind of gets to the point a bit
more I mean it's more documentation to
do but that's fine so be it
um yeah so but yeah actually cheap would
be a good thing I gotta get on that
um that's the thing I should have done a
lot for the for the sake of time let me
just jump to it because there's two more
demos you wanted to show off that
highlight uh 0.7 and then we got several
questions so I think just let me just
jump to those right now too because uh I
I at least know this this next tier you
you were pretty Keen to share as well
um so yeah g in in 0.7
um there's a new OP stylized function
which is sort of like applying and
you're about to show us but it's sort of
like applying sort of a theme to a table
so you could have multiple tables with
with minimum effort to kind of have
different similar looking tables or
similar themes applied to it so yeah
could you provide an example yeah or two
with the new styling function uh yeah
what kind of tables can you make with
that can you extend that with your own
tweaks
um and then second part question which I
asked you and I know I've seen uh is you
know similar to ggplot themes where it's
really easy to build your own theme is
there what kind of support is there for
that now for building your own theme
like a company theme or a personal theme
and uh playing that yeah so thanks yeah
I can definitely get to all those things
uh so yeah the new OP stylized function
it's great
um
I mean let me show you so I'll make a
table and I'll show you that table we're
finally seeing a table which is kind of
cool
um so I'm gonna run that and get it
right here in the viewer okay so here's
my table
um
so this is just like the defaulty look
like just a plain table coming out I
mean it's a bit of formatting there's
like all the different sections like
summary rows this is a grand summary as
you can see by the double line and it's
got some like you know it's got a footer
section a title A stub on the side
um and uh group summary rows great it's
got all the all the other parts are
there uh but now we can we can style
them uh so yeah we just got up stylize
and look at this there's like so many
options because there's six colors uh
that we chose
and six different styles that makes
three six different you know like
jumping off points so
so let's let's show you a few of them
here's one okay
so look at that uh so it does styling
and that's in the blue color we have
cyan
that I'm just going to run through them
pink
red
and great so why do we have just these
colors
the reason is we want to sort of
carefully curate this in order to get
maximum contrast uh between like you
know like the text and the background
colors and just to get some some sort of
Harmony we chose actually a number of
different Hues and it's more apparent we
look at different
um like the different themes like the
different numbered Styles like for
instance this one it has like a dark
blue and a lighter blue and uh perhaps
even lighter blue or yeah something in
the middle
there's actually five different Hues for
each color
and
it's interesting like I called these
Styles one you know just one to five and
then just last night when I was like
preparing this I was like maybe you
should have names for these different
um styles so I took a stab at this you
know like this is like almost like a
colorful stub
because at least you do get a color
there
uh this one draws your attention to the
summaries because
both of them have a background color
uh this one is dominantly gray
but at least has some color at the top
right there
and this one has you know a different
style in terms of like dashed lines
quite a few of them so I try to make it
a little bit different so you have
jumping off points because this may not
be the thing you really want in the end
like if it is that's you know it's
fantastic
um but it might you know it might need
some tweaks right but the great thing is
you can do that uh because all the
changes you make are sort of like
additive in the end uh so we have this
example table for instance and we use
off stylize
uh style five color green
looks pretty good but maybe you don't
want the roast writing we can sort of
see that here in rows two and four and
further down as well uh we can get rid
of that just with Optical stripe being
false
now that is going to be gone oh sorry I
included the pipe
try it again
there we go so that's a that's a tweet
we made so away from like the original
sort of like theme uh result uh maybe
you don't want the outline that's around
the table you can remove that as well
great now we're getting somewhere uh so
you want the table header to be aligned
left no problem we can do that nothing
else is disrupted it's basically just
like independent of everything else and
maybe you want some other options like
and there's tons of these I kind of like
I'm both proud and also a little bit
embarrassed about how many options are
in tab options
so it's a bit unwieldy but it gives you
at least tons of control like over the
look of the table and it's not hard to
use once you know where to look
uh why are you embarrassed about that
like are you suggesting there's like
look at the help article it's you know
it's massive uh so tab options
um I believe this is an area where we
can like we can just scroll and scroll
and scroll
I mean this is okay I mean I think
ggplot has something similar to this
although it kind of breaks it down a bit
more
um
but you know it is at least all in one
function it's kind of like um it's it's
a lot and there's lots of explanation at
least but
you know I can understand it would
overwhelm
um there's some examples more than the
usual amount but I believe this deserves
like an article uh
just to you know go through all these
things but
if you do need to change things table
wide and not have to resort to like
targeting specific areas with tap style
uh this is a pretty good place to go
uh so for instance we can change like
the the vertical lines and just get
Rhythm click none uh we can add a top
and bottom border to the table so let's
take a look at that whole thing
there we go so now we have that line
there and this line down here at the
bottom and the theme it's weird it has
like invisible things that are not
turned on so um
if you do turn them on like this it'll
be part of the theme although it's kind
of like not there sometimes
a little bit strange
um
but yeah so this is an example of like
taking it further you know starting with
OP style eyes and then you know like uh
tweaking into your satisfaction so if
you're like a company a one with one
like your logo in there
um you can probably do that just by
inserting like an SVG or some sort of
graphic in the header or above that
um unfortunately I don't have an example
of that
um but maybe I'll have that for next
time because that seems like a pretty
obvious thing
uh okay more about them so say you want
to do this all the time you could
definitely make your own function uh so
I have a function here called my theme
uh pretty simple all I did was I took
this right here replaced example table
with data but that's you know the only
argument in the function of my theme and
then
um this should totally work I mean even
if you don't have these parts like if
you don't have like a tape like a header
this the function won't stop it will
just do with it what it will and not
error out
so this is kind of cool so my team we
have that function
here's the example table and here's the
example table with my theme
there we go
and is that additive on top of it too
like if I wanted to then suppose there's
a company theme and I then wanted to
take it you can keep going yeah you can
add different options you can have as
many tab options calls as you want
like that so yeah definitely
um so yeah my theme so even more about
theater if you really want to make your
own thing and maybe bypass hop stylize
you know just go a different direction
you can make you know I call this
function my super custom theme same sort
of idea data is like the argument you
can call anything a lot it's basically
just the GT table
and you know used to have options and
again it's huge but it kind of like lets
you target different areas this is just
at random so it's going to look it's
gonna look terrible but I wanted to show
you this oh and also isn't this cool
like the new IDE for our studio shows
the colors that is so incredibly helpful
um
because sometimes I'm just guessing and
if it shows a color it's like oh yeah I
got the color right
so yeah let me show you that so this is
my week that's helpful yeah but yeah
it's steel blue yeah like I'm just
guessing old names that I might have
known okay here's the example table and
this is what my super custom theme apply
there we go so basically
it's like making your own op stylized
function in a way and this is kind of
what up stylizes mainly doing in the in
the body itself of the function
sort of an inside look uh but yeah
here's the table
so all the different sections are styled
according to this
so it can be
um
where do you think development is going
to go with this
um I I've poked you about this before
I've seen one one or two messages on
Twitter where yeah like like the GD plot
is sort of a really nice standard as I
understand it's a pretty good nice
standard
um is this sort of the way you're going
to be encouraging people to have this
sort of uh theme that you could apply to
multiple tables I think so I think so
like you can either do like you know
just have like the different you know
statements or you wrap it up in your own
custom function I think this is the way
to go and just maybe some more
documentation around this because
sometimes it's hard to imagine you can
do that
um yeah or whether it would work really
well but you know having a little
recommendation there in the docs would
be uh my next step with this
because I think the model is not bad I
mean you can overwrite things it's kind
of like a settings table which is just
basically like you know like just set I
guess or
and uh
yeah it's nice that you can sort of
iterate rapidly you know with this
instrument the function change a few
things run it again and then you have a
function you can use over and over again
um we have a bunch of questions coming
in and some will get to in a moment but
one is actually very much uh fit to to
what we're talking about now
um so max actually Max would you like to
ask the question it's I mean it's just
not based on what's on the screen right
now
uh sure thanks yeah um yeah first great
Prat great package um some really cool
things here but I was just wondering
what the kind of design distinction is
between having a function in the opt
set of functions opt underscore and then
having tab options like why would
something be in tab options and not up
stylize yeah yeah I think part of it is
tab options just being so big it's hard
to find important things out of that so
basically what we did with opt functions
is
try to elevate a few things that were
hard to find or it is a combination of
things of different settings which are
changed in tandem which might be not you
know incredibly not obvious
at all uh like for instance
uh well I'm not gonna go through the
code but
the opt stylized that changes a bunch of
things in tab options instead and it
provides a simple interface you just
need to have a style number and then
just have a color that's you know one of
the accepted colors it'll change a bunch
of things for you to have options so
you'll have to hunt through them and
like especially set things there's like
at least like two dozen things which are
changed with just this function
um things with striping it just that is
less the case I mean there's probably an
option inside uh top options that does
that but this just elevates it and
exposes it uh makes it a little bit
easier to find and discover so that's
some of the things either it's like way
too complicated or it's hard to discover
those are the things that sort of
Warrant or maybe think that the opt
functions you know have a place in this
package
okay great thanks that makes sense
any more questions
it's good there there's some that are
that are sort of out of this context
yeah so like I I didn't want to this is
just a perfect fit for here so yeah yeah
that's great
I've also got more if you you're okay
with me showing it to you yeah yeah go
ahead we and maybe after this we'll
switch to I have there are so many
questions on Twitter that kind of fit
into nice themes that I think would
cover a lot of uh questions that people
have so we'll get to those right after
that yeah okay I I just I did this last
night like this little document I was
like I just want to keep going because
of this it was kind of nice so maybe
that's in version 0.8 preview I have
like one function I do want to show uh
which is really super neat it's like
it's been asked about for a while it's
basically just like a find and replace
you know with whatever value with a new
value and it's fine it's kind of nice
actually
um I don't know why I didn't get to it
earlier but uh anyways anyway it will be
here soon with 0.8
uh the function is called sub values and
the idea is okay I'll just make this
table
great and so if I just showed GTE just
to get like a basis so you have this
table this make believe table
and uh there may be a scenario where you
just want to place certain values like
you know like 74 and 500 are just like
example values they're just literals
like you're just searching for them and
you want to replace with some other
value so you can totally do that here
it's an easy interface just for like
making quick tweaks
and it's kind of nice because you can
format these values before and then just
like Sub in some new values and it
doesn't it doesn't like affect or alter
any formatting you've done
which is pretty cool uh so like you know
a value like B could be replaced with
the word b or 800 it could be 800 like
this
so it can't be flexible it could be
different types here it just searches
all across the table
you can definitely constrain across
certain columns if you don't want the
you know replacement to be like too much
um but at simplest is basically looking
at all values and just it's simple find
replace either literals
uh here we can use a pattern like a
regex and then do replacement
so here it could be a C or E is replaced
with the word Ace
and then if you really want something uh
a bit more flexible you can just have
your function in there and then do a
search across values or whatever you
want to do to Target uh values so in
this case any value which is greater
than or less than 50. uh we'll get this
text
that's kind of cool because it just
skips over things which are like
character columns it doesn't like
stumble over those and error it out
so that's a little preview sort of like
the post-credits scene I guess you can
say for this
um
yeah yeah I want to show you that
awesome
well if we could uh switch to some
participant questions uh I'm gonna jump
to slido first so those were the
anonymous questions and also just to
remind everyone uh feel free to drop any
comments or discussion topics or
questions into the zoom chats if you
want to do uh Anonymous we have a little
slider link that I'll share and chat in
just a moment and you can ask those
there there's also a nice poll that will
be a discussion topic as well
um but yeah so first anonymous question
is uh yeah what is your current support
for law Tech at the moment uh personally
I much prefer HTML but for scientific
Publications we are asked to provide the
law Tech file and then also I guess
fitting to that what would be your
suggested workflow like a lot of a lot
of docs are sort of assume I'm going to
do everything in our markdown dock or
everything in a quarto dock and that's
my the thing I submit but very often you
know I just need to make a table that
then a co-author uh incorporates into an
existing you know highly customized law
Tech talk
yeah so you're sort of exporting a note
are you using GT as a tool to make that
table but ultimately you're going to
take that code and put it in a different
document not sort of away from like
armor down a quarter
yeah I think with the tech we want to
make it better it's not nearly close to
parity uh with HTML as it could be I
mean certainly some things that are in
HTML can't be in latex because it's
passionate but a lot of things can't
like cell backgrounds and changing
colors and having just Rawl attack text
if you want to sort of inject that
that's sort of missing
um the reason why it's missing is
because I didn't see there's much demand
for that yet usually when I look at the
tech tables
um they're pretty unadorned with things
like color and other things like that
they're pretty much almost like bog
standard tables
I kind of have to wonder if that's
because it's just really hard to make
tables with you know all sorts of things
in it uh because you have to use
packages and things like that
um but I almost feel like if you had the
option maybe some people would use that
so
it's kind of at that weird standstill
right we don't really know how much we
need to do in that if it's you know like
if that export option is satisfactory or
not
certainly I get the indication that it's
not quite there because some people
prefer to have at least those few things
in there
um so I think we'll address that
I'm gonna be asking you this a couple of
times uh yeah yeah if I was a GT user or
a potential GT user yeah what how do I
let you know what I want I need or would
like lots of ways yeah lots of ways so
yeah the tech tables
I understand
um
basically uh issues issues is a great
obvious way uh other ways is it captures
things and sort of puts it on the record
and it's actionable by me
uh another way is the discussions inside
the GitHub repo for uh GT there's a a
new sort of feature it's not that new
anymore but it's basically a part of
GitHub it's called discussions if you
feel something is not really like an
issue or you just have a question or
something like that
put it in there other places our studio
Community usually I see all this stuff
so that's a great place
um
stack Overflow is not that bad because
you usually have other people answering
your question quickly and it may be just
like you'll find it's a bug so if you'll
just end up you know you might end up
like posting that book as an issue in
in the GT repo uh so lots of ways um
those are the few obvious ways it could
be like
Twitter as well like on the GT
underscore package account
um
you've listed six ways so yeah like the
only option left is like get your email
out or something like that yeah exactly
call me up yeah yeah no I mean yeah
those are those are pretty good ways I
definitely see them like every single
day so if it
if new show comes in I'll try to triage
it and reply back and at least like sort
of like get that like
sort of like in a milestone and
you may not see results for a while but
maybe you will maybe you will so this is
a call you'd love to hear those types of
suggestions or feedbacks yeah well
absolutely either improved the docs if a
feature exists or put it on the on the
pipeline uh if it becomes a priority
yeah and I just had like a few recent
issues about docs about sometimes or
certain parts are confusing uh you know
they don't rebel I love stuff like that
because like
I want to know what's confusing like
maybe at the time it was even confusing
to me but I just you know sort of had to
you know put that in
um
but and sometimes things need revisions
just because things change in weird ways
and you know the docs get stale uh but I
definitely want to hear that and it
seems like also if you're willing to
like make a PR
I would love that too because I can
guide the pr process you know make
little changes make suggestions whatever
your level of comfort is the pr
especially for things like dogs because
that's an easy sort of way to like make
a big impact it's just just changing
text really
um yeah yeah I love all the issues I
will I will work with you to summarize
these this kind of advice and make sure
it's in the video description uh as
we'll share it afterwards
um there's a quick question from slido
as well so this is not GT related but
when you showed the um color
highlighting in our studio IDE
um yeah how do you turn that on or is it
just or I guess I think it's
automatically turned on there might be
an option to turn it off I think there
is an option to turn it off but with
mine it was by default on and where I
got that was from our studio a daily
release uh so if you go to
dailies.orstudio.com that's where all
these
um you know very recent like builds of
the IDE live
um they're pretty they're pretty stable
I use them once in a mile just so I can
catch up on what's new uh but I really
you know some of these things are great
like the color thing is
it's like a dream I never asked for it
but I don't know I love it it's nice if
using colors like any and you do that in
GT a lot so it's great to see that it's
verified
you get it right
um so another question
um from actually is is I'm going to
mispronounce your name sorry about his
aird here erdi I asked a question early
on
give a couple more seconds and just read
the questions yeah
cool well uh kind of earlier in the
discussion
um Ernie had asked uh in my work I often
produced A4 output and PDF uh mainly
with ggplot content it would be nice to
be able to combine gdplot plus GT tables
in a similar way uh to how Patchwork
Works
um having the plot on the table next to
it is very useful sometimes how would uh
interactive GT tables be different from
reactable to I guess that's a different
I said actually topic we'll get to in a
moment yeah yeah yeah but for the first
one uh GTE Patchwork I can totally see
the the appeal of like arranging plots
with tables in a sort of like nice way
um
I think some early sort of like looking
at that was done uh mostly by Ellis and
I believe Tom as well uh so we're
looking into that it seems like a
difficult thing kind of like one of
those High difficulty but High reward
sort of like projects
um
although it does seem like it would be
like a slam dunk if you got that in as a
real feature
I mean there's so many things Chris but
that that is like a good one especially
um
you know as it relates to like our new
publishing Endeavors with quarto
um and I'll actually check in to see if
like
quarto could do some of this as well
as a
as a replacement but
as a another way of like arrange
arranging like these things together
um but yeah we're looking into that
essentially is the short answer maybe
not a very satisfying answer
that's fine um so uh another kind of big
theme uh so you know ahead of time we
had posed this quick the kind of a
question on on your on Twitter uh and
there's a couple similar questions in
here as well
um let me set this up
uh
there set it up so um okay yeah
basically would you like interactive
tables with GTE there's there's been a
couple questions and and at least one
question in in um zoom and slido and
then these as well so yeah I'm kind of
curious what your thoughts are on the
ability to add interactivity uh
reactable is obviously very is already
very popular for doing uh creating
interactive or you know having having
interactive features added to a table so
yeah I'm just curious what your thoughts
are
um yeah I'll say like this is like a
thing we want
um to highlight a couple big points
right is search in fact my you can see
my comment there is the third one
um you know search and uh kind of column
filters that sort of thing yeah well the
great thing about reactable is that we
can use that as infrastructure for GT
I actually have a branch
um it's not really a PR yet but it's
like an experimental branch of GT that
has like interactive tables and it
basically uses reactable under the hood
so we can apply the same sort of API
things that GT has uh but just use
reactable as the engine for producing
tables
um to make this work nicely we have to
make sure that all the styling and all
the things that you expect come through
um
we have to know like you know like not
no but we have to figure out you know
how summary rows would work inside of
like this new interactive table maybe
they don't work but um we want to make
sure the look and feel is sort of
retained but still using like you know
like all the work that's been done
reactable because I think it's kind of
like
a little bit not counterproductive but a
little bit too much work to like
reinvent you know like another like
interactive table project just for like
one feature
so that's something I've been exploring
and the early results are pretty good
like you get all the features you get
the search and you get like the
filtering
um you know like all that all that good
stuff and you can turn them on
selectively as you would with reactable
uh it's just so you don't have to type
out a bunch of reactable code you just
use GT code maybe switch an option a few
more things in tab options for you know
switching things around and then you're
pretty much there in the same place
in the community help in some way or
start testing things out yes yeah my
first thing is to make that through
public as a PR and make an issue that
pairs with that and then just a you know
like uh illicit comments um from the
community I think that'd be great yeah
um and then you know publicize that a
bit so people actually know that that's
being you know done
um
yeah yeah that'd be good I'll have that
I'll have that going like thanks to this
week actually no it's actually a good
thing that's testing it recently and
like it's a thing that's constantly
asked and
you know it's a big thing but to be able
to push across the Finish Line you just
have to like you know
you know get back to it and you know
work on it so yeah that's great that's
great
uh there's another question from Zoom uh
is Arthur still here would you like to
ask you sorry you asked it uh probably
at least 40 minutes ago so
if I can't catch you this is what the
question was I'm dropping into chat
right now okay uh is Arthur there by
chance yes awesome okay
yeah so the question is is is this so
like GTS is a nice way where you can
kind of style
um rows that may kind of defy a certain
validation rule let's say
um but currently it seems like one needs
to you know add a new tab style per per
rule are there any thoughts for making
this easier like um I don't know
something like our D player across or
some other way of like kind of
implementing this across several like
applying to several columns yeah I
believe you can do that
um you have one rule for how you're in
style and then you have multiple columns
is it better of columns or you could do
tie slot you can just wear uh you know
like where is numeric for instance would
be one thing
um
yeah let me know if that doesn't work
because like my careers are saying is
you just Supply a vector of columns or
any sort of ties like statement uh
should do it
I believe if you do that the columns all
have to exist
uh no actually if you just include a
vector of the alt exist if you're using
tie select they don't you can use like
something like begins with or it starts
starts with or ends with things like
that
um
does that answer your question yeah I
think so thanks I'll tinker and uh come
back to you if uh yeah if it doesn't
work as expected yeah yeah it doesn't
work definitely let me know because like
yeah
so I I this is another question that I
really wanted to ask you
um this is a question that came from
LinkedIn from Jean-Claude
um and the the what the what part of the
reason why I want to bug you about this
is uh when you gave your talk at our
studio conf in 2019 you had a question
for the audience that was this as well
yeah so I think I yeah so Excel output
is basically the question it'd be a huge
Improvement I often have to produce
tabular output that would be easily used
usually it means Excel tables so far
mainly do this in Python uh with some
libraries a simple in our solution would
be great preferably with full control
over cell numeric formatting borders
merge sales replacement that sort of
thing if you could do that by Christmas
that would be awesome awesome
yeah I've heard this a long time ago I I
wasn't sure how many people would do
this because it seemed like there was
already Solutions in place for doing
this but not really right like not with
the API that GT has
um
so this may be a thing like this would
definitely come way before like
something like PowerPoint that does also
asked for
um
so yeah it's not in there because you
didn't ask for it exactly what type of
table I put are you so docx is Big I'm
thinking like anything office is kind of
big because like office is Big so
um but I'm hoping with the new docx uh
stuff that we have in
things like PowerPoint and Excel are not
too far off because they both use XML
and we're using the XML basically it's
open access open XML
code generation to to create That Word
document
uh nice so it might be yeah it might be
close like it might align like very
closely with Excel as far as I know like
each tag has like the name of like the
office product in the front of it and
then like you know it's used but I'm not
sure if there's like different
Arrangements of the 10x depending on the
output format but I want to say it's
pretty close
um
so it may not be something that's like
totally like new and like an entirely
like separate project it might be like
just part of like the the word or office
project as it were
so I'll look into that like the first
part is sort of like investigating you
know like like how much work will be
like an estimating
but I've heard this time and again like
Excel is kind of like a big thing so it
you know it's kind of impossible to
ignore at this point
so yeah basically I'm gonna look into
that as well
cool we we just got a bunch of questions
coming in
um with four minutes left so first off
are you able to go after like it'd be
nice to maybe do we could do a little
summary for at the hour of uh how to get
in touch with you kind of go over those
the kind of calls to action you might
have and then uh you know whether or not
those folks are able to stick around we
could at least just get those questions
answered so that there's a record of it
um yeah so first off uh in in the video
description and uh associated with this
you kind of went over ways to get in
touch with you
um and so we'll share those as well I
saw Isabella actually share those in
Zoom chat yeah
um I did want to call out something as
well uh tomorrow right you have a
workshop at R and Pharma uh it's free
it's if you if you just Google R and
Pharma 2022 workshops you'll get a nice
list of them and uh you want to add the
event byte group
um and can you it's not GTA it's not
tables can you kind of walk through what
you're presenting tomorrow yeah it's a
different package I work on called Point
Blank and uh yeah totally different than
GTE although it does use GT to make the
reporting uh the tables as it were
um but it's different it's all about
like validating your data like uh you
know validation rules things like that
to make sure you have direct data and
it's also
um concerned with data documentation
so in the outputs you do you do get GT
tables which is kind of nice because
um I'm basically programming with GT so
it is possible to like use GT as like
infrastructure for generating reports
so that's what that package does so
basically during that three hour
workshop I'll be going through
um all sorts of things dealing with data
validation and data documentation
basically like making data dictionaries
the and it's free work workshops closed
now so I was mistaken I thought it was
open uh is it gonna be recorded like how
would people get yeah it's gonna be
recorded and I do have all my workshop
materials available uh somewhere it's in
the repo called your docs are great I've
seen those yeah yeah it's a repeat book
called Point Blank uh Workshop
and it has like everything there I'm
going to share that just here in the
zoom chat
and it's nice because I uh there's a rco
cloud project there so you can just run
all the rmds
it's basically an example based or
yeah mostly an example based workshop
I'll be running through all these things
explaining things uh changing things up
inviting q a throughout
um so hopefully within a three hours you
have some sort of like handle on how to
use like the package yeah is that in our
studio package
it is not it's my answer personal
project you're an open source Maniac
you're just creating I mean yeah I do
some things on the side yeah
yeah but yeah well just just to sum up
for the hour so folks who need to leave
uh are able to so thank you very much
this was our inaugural pilot uh open
source chat uh with our guests Rich
we'll get through uh as many questions
as Rich has time for afterwards so feel
free to stick around
um if you asked a question but weren't
able to stick around have a look at on
YouTube well we'll publish this a bit
later uh where you could see that
discussion so thank you everyone for
hanging out and participating and
definitely reach out to Rich uh
regarding kind of feedback and comments
in the ways that uh he's gone over again
if you didn't catch that check out the
video description and our follow-up
we'll kind of cover out all of those
ways to help make GT and open source
software for data science better and
just again thank you for being excited
about participating in this and
contributing in your own ways we really
appreciate it thank you thank you have
lots of fun
cool so as uh some folks are going to be
dropping off no no worries and uh I I
did not double check with you how much
time you have left over but maybe we
could just kind of jump through as many
questions as you can or just let me know
absolutely
sweet so um Nathan uh had asked a
question in fact he had warned us he was
going to ask a question and then ask the
question so I want to make sure I get to
him is Nathan there by chance or did he
jump off
I think he jumped off
um yeah so are there
uh I'm gonna I think I'm gonna copy
paste it so it's the most recent
question in Zoom uh Nathan uh are there
ways to have grouped rows I mean uh when
repeated rows have same characters we
can merge them into one oh yeah yeah we
do have Ashley so we have Road groups
it's not well documented or exposed yet
I do have some examples but essentially
you do row group as column as a tab
option option and then what it does is
it takes the road group that's
customarily at the top of the label
running across and it puts it on the
leftmost side in this tab uh and it
doesn't repeat you know across multiple
rows it just shows it once so that's
basically like
I hope that's what you expect like you
just get like it show them once at the
top and then all the other like rows in
that group
um are just you know like labeled
uh and Steve actually had a Steve varola
had a suggestion as well um okay yeah do
you have it um do you know what it is I
do yeah let me let me just drop it in
the chat yeah so some of the contexts
I'm a little bit missing on so I may I
may have missed a little bit of a
context oh yeah yeah that's great this
is perfect this is showing tie select so
you can totally do this like where is
numeric where is Factor uh this is great
because like if you use for my currency
on cons which are not numeric
um it won't work so yeah basically this
is like pretty sweet yeah yeah so I just
wanted to note I'm the one since I wrote
it in there yeah I use that when I know
everything's numeric but any of the tiny
select I've I found work you can do
contains I contains starts with ends
with all of that works perfectly in
quarto that's that's typically where
I've used GT yeah and the great thing
about Tice left instead of using
explicit column names is it won't fail
on you if it doesn't Define those
columns it won't like you know error if
you put explicit column names an
expectation is that you have all those
column names in there and it will
uh cause a stop where so yeah Ty select
it's good stuff
uh Brittany B has a at least at least
one question I think two questions um
would you be willing to ask those
Brittany
sure um so the first question is kind of
like trying to get GT to be like an
Excel screenshot
um so at my company one of the standards
that they put around tables is that your
table should have column letters and row
numbers so that you can reference things
like B5 or something like that is there
a way to get that into GT tables
sort of uh so you prefer to have like
the like B1 at the top above a column
name
right yeah you could you just have to
introduce like a line break and use
markdown formatting for each of the
column names
um the trick there is how do you make a
line break at all uh well at least with
like
um with markdown you have to use two
spaces then slash in I'm gonna write
that in the chat
because it's not incredibly obvious
actually it's really hard to know this
um see if I can write this like this
so if you have that in your column name
like say you have like the
of course you have to generate the the
the letters yourself
um but it's not gonna be too bad to do
that the trick is to get a line break uh
to work you have to use that and then
make sure you use calls label and then
um use markdown like the empty keyword
or uh function
and then it should render nicely like
with a break and then like with the
actual column name
what about the rose okay so when you
want the rose to be sort of a separate
looking almost column yeah that's more
difficult because before it was not easy
to use for rent markdown unlike the row
labels
uh but in a recent change to 0.8 which
is yet to be released that's not
possible uh you can use front markdown
on a column which is like the stud
and if you don't have a stub at all same
you just use front-up markdown I didn't
use the same trick here
uh but yeah it definitely use piece to
get this going
or good
Brittany you also have another question
and I feel that that this question
actually should this I feel like this
should be a blog post that yeah I get
this question so often and because it's
so difficult to like we don't have like
uh we don't have a bunch of like nice
performances for like doing little
obvious things like line breaks
uh and other little things like that in
GT unfortunately or you know subscripts
or superscripts
um and you know we can't deliver
markdown like at least the last thing I
talked about the subscription
superscripts uh but you can at least do
line breaks which is very common uh but
I don't really have that anywhere in an
article I don't believe
or very much it doesn't take you into
the help articles too much so I think I
should like try to get that in there as
much as possible
or try to make
some other uh I can't think of another
way of doing it but there's got to be
another way of doing it
um
um Brittany also had another question
um and you had brought this up earlier
but uh yeah Brittany would you like to
ask it or yeah yeah I can jump in so do
you have any suggestions um so I'm kind
of like the resident uh R expert on my
team so I'm doing a lot of things like
trying to
um take some of those like templates or
things from Word documents and like one
page or templates that analysts will put
together around like a thing that they
did
um I'm trying to incorporate that into R
and I've done it with ggplot where you
can actually put the corporate colors in
there and the
um like fonts and things like that but
is there something similar or do you
have suggestions for how I could maybe
build out a similar type of function but
for like DT tables yeah certainly uh so
just going back to this
pressure my screen quickly uh right here
doing a bit of this would be good
um but it doesn't get to the part where
you actually introduce Graphics to the
header
um
which is kind of tough It's almost like
you want to make like a I don't have an
example unfortunately but you could put
a graphic into like the header at least
just by using HTML and then doing
something like this um this is not going
to be a full example in the time the
restram you have but we can use tab
header
you can at least have like title and in
something like HTML and then put in like
your custom HTML in there which can
include graphics and things like that
into this part
um
I wish I had an example and I could just
show you but this is I think this is the
key if you want to put that in there
that would work and it may not work in
the custom theme part but maybe it would
with just some tinkering so this is
definitely another blog post idea
or article idea I think because
I kind of wish I had an easy solution
for this
um but I think this is like the the way
to at least get into the header
uh and this is kind of the way to set
all the different like you know colors
and styles for the rest of the table
so maybe to be continued more on this
soon because like
not incredibly obvious how to do that
I do sign up to make a list of
everything you've either promised or
half promised so that yeah at least at
least that's hanging over you in some
issue somewhere yeah yeah
some things I just lose a little bit of
track of
um uh but I definitely want
certain things to double up and be in my
family again for sure
um I think we hit every question I did
want to acknowledge that um erity who I
think is still on uh you know would have
been happy to ask his question or her
question but was uh uh was a was away at
the moment or had already had internet
issues but there so I I as far as I
could tell I think we've kind of gone
through all of the the audience
questions as well as the the ones from
uh Twitter I sort of grouped a lot of
them together because there were common
themes about out preferred output
formats or desired output formats there
were sort of two sets of questions
regarding interactivity which is uh just
generally or like some and then also
Focus mainly on search and filtering
um but yeah like I this is pretty much
it unless folks would like to ask
something additional feel free to just
open up your mic or or pose it in in
chat but otherwise I think we think
we're all good yeah and again be not
afraid to like host issues
I love issues like I said like they they
sort of steer me into doing things like
into priorities essentially so yeah
definitely open an issue
if you can
and you may have got this earlier
because I came in a little bit late but
um one of the things that I've noticed
and Googling it it seemed like there's
some other people mention it as well
with PDF output for wide tables it
doesn't shrink it down like it is on
HTML if you're in PDF yeah that's right
um it could be like I'm not using like
the right long table uh options for that
there might be something already in long
table which is what we standardized on
and I think what a lot of like
um
um like software that generates tables
like pandok have standard on
standardized on for for tables
um it could be just there's so many
things we could be doing in in the long
table context
but maybe we're just not getting there
yet at least we split across tables we
don't repeat columns half the time so
that's a area of work for latex output
that's you know
even coming before like styling of okay
do you have an issue on that yet or
should is that something that I should
follow up with as well because I Steve I
think asked in Twitter as well I think
if I yeah correctly you have an issue if
there's already an issue boarded up okay
you know Make some noise on the issue if
it
totally like affects your your workflow
yeah makes sense thanks welcome
unless anyone else yeah thank you so
much
um for participating really appreciate
this pilot in two weeks we're gonna have
another one where Greg Lynn who's the
package maintainer of reactable is going
to be joining us uh for the same formats
um so looking hopefully y'all could join
uh looking forward to participating in
that and well that's looking forward
just to be clear thank you so much Rich
for doing all this with us and sharing
all of us really appreciate it yeah
foreign
[Music]